it's august 2nd
2020 so time for another monthly update
video i'm going to talk a bit about
what went on in july and what we've got
coming up in august
first i always like to begin with three
big things
big thing number one i'm turning 50 this
month
and so i'm going to be having a birthday
bash
online using youtube live
it's not totally interactive of course
but we'll all be able to raise a glass
together
at a certain point in the the bash and
and that'll be quite nice
so i hope that you can join me there it
won't be on my actual
birthday because the democratic national
convention will be going on
just not even a block from here so i i
it's a little dicey whether it can
happen or not
on my actual birthday so we we moved it
to the the 16th instead
big thing number two and this applies to
this week uh wisdom for life the radio
show that i host with dan hayes here in
milwaukee
is going to be having its 20th episode
coming up on
next saturday now we do our recording
for it on wednesday night and then it
plays
on saturday and this time we're looking
for
questions comments topics that listeners
want
us to grapple with we're going to do k
you know 20 episodes is kind of a big
deal
so we're going to do a special show just
about that
and about what wisdom of life wisdom for
life is about and
and so if you have questions about how
to apply
philosophy in everyday life fairly
specific questions
go ahead and shoot them to us i'll put
information for that below
and big thing number three
it happened in july just finished up
happening
at the end of the month the saddlers
lectures
podcast which is me taking some of my
core concept videos and turning them
into high quality
podcast episodes we reached the 200
episode mark so that's kind of another
important benchmark
so if you haven't listened to the
sadler's lectures podcast or if you're
one of these people
who keeps asking me hey when are you
going to turn these videos into podcasts
it's there check it out so those are the
three
big things for this month so what went
on
in the month of july well i've been
doing
lots and lots of online teaching lots of
client work tutorials philosophical
counseling consulting work
there's been a lot of behind the scenes
action on
the modern stoicism organization and
stoicism today and getting
prepared for you know a virtual stoic
han
and we're probably also going to have a
stoic on x here in milwaukee
virtually of course and um what else
recording episodes for wisdom for life
links to those are below we've got a
consistent production schedule going on
the podcast uh has been going along
quite well i'll tell you about that in
just just a minute
but i was also on a podcast episode
an interview for the modern stoicism
podcast recently started up
i'll put a link to that below as well
and
uh quite a few online events we held the
half hour hegel
sessions for q a and stuff like that the
political
theory and practice online event the ama
that's ask me anything
we did our monthly stoic fellowship and
of course you may not know about this
but we started up
in a new format the worlds of
speculative fiction with
cordweiner smith one of my favorite
authors
the writer of the game of rat and dragon
scanners live in vain and so many other
great short stories born right here in
milwaukee by the way but although he
didn't live his life
here in milwaukee so he's not really a
milwaukee and in any
real respect other than birth and
we we held you know the we had the video
for it that people were
able to to watch and respond to and then
we had a video conferencing session
that went quite well so we're going to
be continuing that this coming
month what else you know
normally at this time i'd be having my
my kids up here
but of course kovid 19 and the pandemic
and the uh you know essentially out of
control
nature of of things here in wisconsin we
can't even go to chicago without having
a 14-day quarantine
in part because the republicans have you
know so so you know
handicapped any sort of uh state
response unfortunately
means that my my kids weren't able to to
come up here so we've been doing things
back
and forth but it's you know it's kind of
strange times and i think many of you
can relate to that not being able to see
friends and family and being in this
virtual environment all the time
a lot of my students are are having
similar struggles going on
as well as they talk about in the online
classes
what else is going on been taking a lot
of walks you know for exercise
actually i've lost something like
15 pounds since since
i i first you know made the challenge of
getting down to
uh losing 30 pounds getting down from
290 to 260 or so round numbers they're
not actually
i think it's like 292 or something like
that
um so i'm actually making good progress
on that um i do
miss going to the gym turns out i found
out that our gym
has been open of course i haven't been
going because uh
they they're they can't really guarantee
anything and i found out that
now they're finally actually requiring
masks in the gym
so this entire time people have been not
doing that in the downtown
so all right enough of that stuff let's
talk about podcasts
um i did a lot of stuff in the sadler's
lectures podcast as i mentioned we
hit we hit the 200 episode mark with the
last release on
gabriel marcel i found two
kant episodes that i had failed to
release uh when i was releasing all the
rest of them it's kind of easy in
soundcloud
so i released those i released an entire
sequence on gabriel marcel's on the
ontological mystery
an entire sequence on albert camus the
myth of sisyphus
four episodes on john rawls theory of
justice and we were finishing up with
some of the aristotle
episodes as well in early
july so i i actually probably got out
about a podcast episode today
maybe not 31 but pretty close to it
video um some of you may have noticed
that
i shot two new kinds of videos this
month
one of which is just footage of and it
says
just flowers bees and butterflies
you know when i go out on these walks
around town one of the cool things about
milwaukee is there's so much green space
the legacy actually of our socialist
past here
in milwaukee many of the people who
decided things for
for our um town as it was growing
were in fact members of the socialist
party and they ensured that there would
be parks for the people and so we
benefit from that way more than most
other
midwestern cities do so that's that's
really quite cool
we have something like four times the
green space
of chicago per capita uh and
it really you can really tell it when
you when you drive around in this this
city
so i've been taking video of some of my
favorite things i love flowers i really
am into
bees maybe some of you didn't know that
about me both honeybees and bumbles
and the monarch butterfly is something
quite important for
our family i'll probably do a video just
about that so i've been recording those
and setting those to some bach
music and just letting people watch them
to chill out
and enjoy what we have of the summer
going on here
i've also started shooting these saddler
stories
videos as well that people have seemed
to like
and it's just me sitting telling a story
from my past
sometimes it's a story within a story
like the german soldier who
escaped from a russian pow camp during
world war ii and walked all the way back
home
who i met in lebanon missouri when i was
a young soldier myself
so i've been shooting those and i did
manage to get two
book reviews done that was pretty good i
got two half hour hegel videos done
we have video recordings of all of the
wisdom for life
shows when dan and i record them audio
we also record video
as well and all the other events you
know the ama
the political theory the worlds of
speculative fiction all of those are
available
as well in youtube because those are all
online events that were
streaming or scheduled or things like
that
i shot some core concept videos one on
nozix experience machine which a lot of
people were into people have been asking
for nosik for quite a while
and i was covering him in my intro to
philosophy class
and then quite a few videos on david
hume
and the inquiry concerning human
understanding so
that's what went on during july
what have we got coming up in august
it's going to be a
pretty packed month as i mentioned i'm
turning 50
and we're also gearing up for online
classes
many of which are actually starting in
august for fall semester
some of which are starting in september
and i am teaching a full load of classes
this term
as usual i got asked by by several
different places
actually i had to turn some down i've
been asked
to teach quite a few classes because i'm
sort of a known
you know known entity here in the
greater milwaukee area and i have all
this background in teaching and
designing online classes
let's talk about events so on the 4th
that's a tuesday
at 6 00 p.m we're gonna have our
milwaukee sofia meeting
that is the society of philosophers in
america of course that's online
all of these are online events all of
them all the times i'm giving you are in
central time by the way
so sophia meeting we're going to be more
or less doing some planning for the fall
what what sort of events do we want to
do
what sort of things do we want to
coordinate do we want to bring some
speakers in or what do we want to engage
in
then on the 5th the following day at 5
p.m
i'm going to have my monthly hegel q a
discussion forum held online through
video conferencing
that's open to anybody anybody who who
has an interest in hegel
or in hegelian thought more generally a
dialectical thought
german idealism can pop in and we'll
discuss
matters we've got a core of people who
tend to show up
and join in on that on the 8th that's a
saturday
at 12 p.m i will have my monthly ama
you've got a question
for me you want to bring something up
and find out what i think about it
go ahead and pop in and ask your
question make sure you get them in early
and don't ask it over and over again if
i if i get to it i'll get to it if i if
i don't
you know asking multiple times won't
help you
the reason i say get in early is because
so many people show up
and ask questions that you do want to
make sure that you're
covered so to speak um at 2 p.m that day
i'll be having my philosophy chat for
patreon supporters
at a certain level of support on patreon
that's one of the perks
that you get is a it's not exactly
one-to-one it's more of uh
you know could be one-to-one if you're
the only one who shows up but often
there's two or three people
there and we talk about anything you
want to in philosophy
you get me for an hour and you get to
tap my
my brain about all that sort of stuff
provided i have some competence to talk
about it
later on that day we're also going to be
having that you know
episode 20 of the wisdom for life now
that's
recorded in advance because you know we
can't go into the studio obviously due
to covid
so if you want to ask questions for that
you got to make sure they get in
by wednesday and
we're hoping that we get a lot of cool
topics to discuss from viewers and
listeners
of the show who want to send something
our way and hear themselves talked about
on the air uh and and uh we'll grapple
with their ideas as best as we can
each saturday there'll be another wisdom
for life episode those are airing at 4
p.m
central time every saturday so
um that's sort of a a given every uh
every week on the ninth a sunday at 12
p.m
we're going to have our political theory
and practice discussion that's a live
streaming event
where i present on some topic for about
20 minutes and then people
you know make comments and questions on
the side often times they get into
arguments with each other
and we're this this week or this this
month rather
we're going to be discussing a pressing
issue here in the united states
school openings a lot of schools are
planning on opening face-to-face
the question is are they putting
students faculty
parents other community members at risk
and is that risk
acceptable or should we be having uh
you know much more online and hybrid
education so we'll talk about that
issue which is uh quite pressing
um on the 15th of saturday at 12 p.m
we're going to have the
classic metal class which is a video
conferencing class we also post the
video later on for those who couldn't
make it
this time around we're discussing
mimesis that's imitation and we're
discussing in particular
the issue of tribute bans and the the
economy
of how tribute bands are in some cases
doing better than the
actual bans and what's going on are
tribute bands really bans
or are they just sort of a knockoff in
imitation what you know so there's a lot
of cool philosophical issues
involved in that on the 16th
sunday at 12 p.m we will be having
my 50th birthday bash online i hope that
you can join me for that
i'll be live streaming i'll talk a
little bit about what it's like to
live longer than you ever thought you
would and to be
you know clearly set in middle age when
you still
kind of feel uh in some respects at
least
you know not necessarily bodily but at
least in my mind
like i'm still still a young guy so i'll
talk about all sorts of things you know
maybe a little bit of retrospective
and then you know we'll do a toast maybe
we'll do the toast at the start right
so before i start boring you with
stories and then you know whatever
people want to say i'll i'll respond to
it sort of like an ama
sort of like you know other other live
sessions so hope you can join me for
that celebration
again it's on the 16th not the 18th
which is my actual birthday
because the democratic national
convention will be here and things are
going to be
crazy downtown you know i live less than
a block
from where it's actually going to be
held so things are going to get kind of
kind of wild we expect
um on the 22nd
at 12 and at 1 30 we're going to have
the worlds a speculative
fiction series uh starting up you know
and and we have two online events both
of which
are going to be looking at the the
narrative world
of walter miller now this is the book
that most people know a canticle for
leibowitz
but there was also this follow-up not
quite as good
uh and and not entirely written by
miller
uh st leibowitz and the wild horse woman
so we're going to talk about that
narrative world some
philosophical themes and the way it
takes place
is first i have a video that's going to
premiere which means people can
comment on the side and i'll be joining
them for live chat
as the video runs that'll be about an
hour and a half
and then we'll have an hour and a half
of discussion
via zoom video conferencing for those
who want to have a more
in-depth interaction talking about the
works and the ideas and
all of that sort of stuff so if you can
join us for that that's that you know if
you're interested
in this book and it's follow-up then you
might want to do that
um on the 27th at 6 p.m we have the
milwaukee stoic fellowship which is
now basically worldwide i mean we have
people joining us from arizona
from florida because like like so many
local events
it once it went online other people
could join in so if you're interested
in talking about stoicism pop in the
book that we are looking at
is on tony on macaro's more than
happiness
but you can easily find the information
for that if you go to the mke stoic
fellowship meetup
page which i'll put below and then
finally on the 29th
at 2 p.m we will have another video
premiere i'm starting up the
self-directed studies series again
this time on how to study saint
augustine of hippo and his writings and
where you might start and
what might be helpful for you to keep in
mind
so a lot of events coming up in august
and
you might want to put those on your
calendar you can find them on my reason
io calendar
you can also find them on my facebook
page events um what else do we have
coming up so you know like i mentioned
classes are starting i'm doing a lot of
course building this month
online classes you you like to have
everything built out as much as possible
in advance
so i'm going to be doing that a lot of
shooting videos like framing videos for
them where i'm like hello students
today we're blah blah blah blah right
there's a lot of that go
that goes into it but i am also creating
some new
content for the month as well um
podcasts sadler's lectures we've got
epicurus episodes that i've already
released to my patreon supporters
that i'm releasing this weekend and this
coming week
i'll also be creating some new podcast
episodes on heraclitus
and a number of podcast episodes on
plato
and then we'll see what we do after that
it's really going to depend
on what i need for my my students my
classes right so probably some aristotle
coming up
as well most likely um i'm teaching
existentialism this this coming semester
so you can expect some content
uh either this month or next month in
that respect
let's talk about video as we close this
out so i'm gonna keep
telling sadler's stories since people
seem to like that
and i'll shoot more of those
i've got some book review videos to do
some long overdue things
they sent me this book when it first
came out like in 2018
i really do need to to review it so i'm
going to do that this month
uh this is kind of an apt one uh midlife
a a philosophical guide and then this is
one that got sent to me
quite a long time by hiram krep crespo
who lives
down in the the northwest chicago area
and i've been meaning to get to this one
for
quite a long time quite a good book
attending the epicurean
garden so i've got those book review
videos to do there'll be videos of
course of the events you know like the
ama the political discussion
the um uh wisdom for life
episodes the heavy metal class the 50th
birthday bash the worlds of speculative
fiction
all of that's going to be coming up um
core concept videos i've got some
stuff on foucault i want to shoot and
more hume videos coming out and then
i've got to re
i've got to add some kamu videos that i
never got to
and if i can i'm also going to get to
some more marcel
videos as well
um i also need to do some new videos
on kierkegaard and and some ideas in
dostoyevsky's works
and then of course there's the half hour
hegel series i'm hoping to finally
i'm hoping this is going to be the month
that i actually get back up to shooting
six of those a month i've got a little
bit of momentum going
so i got to keep that wind in my sails
so
that's everything that's coming up again
links everything are down below
you know click the show more or whatever
it is in your interface
and you'll see all the things that i've
been talking about hope to see you in
some of these
online events and
yeah it's going to be a busy month
you